welcome everyone my name is marco de
santis and i am a regulatory affairs
specialist
at the division of therapeutics and
medical consequences or dtmc at the
national institutes on drug abuse
at the national institutes of health
let me introduce you the to the division
first the medications development
program of dtmc was created by
congressional mandate
in 1990 to establish a program to
develop medications for the treatment of
herring and cocaine dependence
since then we have also included
developing medications to treat nicotine
cannabis methamphetamine and
prescription of your dependence
we support a program of basic and
clinical research to develop innovative
pharmacological and non-pharmacological
approaches
for substance use disorders and related
medical and psychiatric conditions
and to investigate the medical
consequences of drug abuse such as hiv
aids and hepatitis among other diseases
gtmc funds research through grants
cooperative agreements and contracts
we collaborate with investigators from
academia the pharmaceutical and
biotechnology sectors and national and
international government agencies as
well
our division is modeled after a typical
pharmaceutical company
dtmc has the capabilities to conduct all
phases of medications development from
screening and synthesis of potential
drug entities
to pharmacological and toxicological
pre-clinical studies
the conduct of clinical trials and the
preparation of submissions for new drug
applications
when it comes to pharmacotherapies for
opioid use disorder or oud
many people with oud benefit from
treatment with medication for very
length of time including lifelong
treatment
we know that ongoing outpatient
medication treatment is linked
to better retention and outcomes than
treatment without medication
so fda-approved medications should be
considered and offered to patients with
oud as part of their treatment
there are three medications approved by
fda for the treatment of opiod
dependence
methadone buprenorphine
and gland
methadone a new opio receptor full
agonist
eliminates withdrawal symptoms
and relieves drug cravings by acting on
autoreceptors in the brain
although it occupies and activates these
receptors it does so more slowly than
other opiates do and in an opi-dependent
person it does not produce euphoria
it comes in two oral formulations for
the treatment of oud
these are a daily tablet
and a daily oral concentrate
buprenorphine is a partial agonist of
the nuclear reception of the receptor it
can only partially activate the receptor
but binds extremely tightly to it
and thus prevents other opiates from
accessing it
it can reduce cravings and withdrawal
symptoms in a person with out without
producing euphoria
like methadone does
for buprenorphine there are two types of
products on the market
the ones containing
solely buprenorphine and the combination
with naloxone
naloxone is an opioid receptor
antagonist that is added to decrease the
likelihood of diversion and misuse of
the combination drug product
for buprenorphine alone the formulations
are a six-month implant
a one-month injection depot and a
sublingual formulation of daily
buprenorphine
for buprenorphine and nandoxan products
there are buccal and sublingual daily
dose formulations
or levo method is acetate is an opioid
receptor agonist that has been
discontinued by the manufacturer and is
currently not commercially available
glam is a synthetic opiate structurally
related to
methadone with properties that allowed
for thrice weekly dosing due to its
active metabolites
lung labeling changed in 2001 to reflect
newly identified safety concerns with qt
interpret prolongation
but fda never requested a market
withdrawal
last we have naltrexone a nokia receptor
antagonist
that works by blocking the effect of
opioid receptors and decreasing cravings
naltrexone is also approved but for the
prevention of relapse to opiod
dependence after detoxification
is currently marketed as an extended
release injectable suspension
administered every four weeks or once a
month
this slide shows the market share of
each of these medications globally as
you can see the buprenorphine segment
accounted for the largest share of the
market
in 2020 due to the greater adoption of
buprenorphine products mainly in the u.s
when it comes to the treatment of
withdrawal symptoms lophexidine is the
only fda approved compound
luffexidine is an alpha-2 adrenergic
agonists that does not interact directly
with the opioid receptor
for the treatment of opioid orbitals
we have available a small variety of
naloxone formulations
naloxone is an opiate receptor
antagonist and it's used to reverse
opioid overdose by attaching to opiate
receptors and blocking the effects
of other opiates
it comes as nissan sprays in two
different doses
and injectables with different dosages
including the recently approved
hydrogens of 5 milligrams
finally there is non-methane amino optic
receptor inverse agonist
with a longer action than naloxone or
naltrexone
it is approved by fda but not currently
on the market
despite the existence of safe and
effective therapeutics of 4ud including
the treatment of opioid operators
there are still limitations to these
pharmacotherapies that need to be
addressed
in order to combat effectively the
ongoing overdose crisis
for the current formulations of
methadone and buprenorphine long-term
efficacy and treatment adherence are
sub-optimal
moreover
these medications are agonists of the
opioid receptor so they have abused
liability and therefore are controlled
substances
nantrexum is approved to prevent objects
relapsing people with no physical
dependence to opiates
but initiation and adherence to
treatment are poor
naloxone is approved to reverse opioid
overdoses
but it has a short action may
precipitate off your withdrawal
and put the person at risk of overdose
especially when fentanyl or fentanyl
analogs are involved
fda approved versions of naloxone can
require a prescription which may be a
barrier for people who aren't under the
care of a physician
or may be ashamed of admitting to issues
with substance abuse
and finally leufexidine is only approved
for adults it is not approved to treat
pregnant women nor neonatal of your
withdrawal syndrome
in an effort to leverage fines to help
address these problems and to produce
more acceptable and effective
medications
dtmc established a pipeline for projects
related to the development
of pharmacotherapeutics for the
treatment of oud at copyright objects
you can see in this slide dtmc's current
medication pipeline summarizing all
efforts that have been pursued so far
it is very exciting to see that the
pipeline consists of 55 projects at
present
13 of them involving the development of
new formulations of already approved
opiates for oud or opioid operators
12 novel compounds in the early
preclinical stage
13 compounds in the late technical stage
and 17 in the clinical space
i'll start describing the projects
corresponding to the new formulations
category
in this category
we are supporting
the development of longer acting
formulations of opiates to improve
compliance and prevent relapse
we are very happy to have in our
pipeline several longer action nutrition
formulation for the treatment of oyug
as i said before naltrexone is only
available as a monthly injection default
and longer acting formulations are
desirable to improve its effectiveness
we have five formulations with potential
dosing strategies ranging from two
months to one year
other candidates for longer active
formulations include weekly oral
formulations for buprenorphine and art
methadone
this would be an improvement to the
daily dosage of available current
formulations for these two drugs
now methine has a longer duration of
action when compared to other objects
and implants lasting six or even two to
three months may effectively prevent
craving and relapse
finally the reintroduction of lambs may
provide a valuable choice due to its
proven behavioral and clinical advantage
with respect to new formulations for the
treatment of opioid orbitals opiate
pharmaceuticals is developing a
nominating international formulation
the objective is to provide a longer
acting blocking effect
than naloxone and prevent respiratory
depression more effectively than
naloxone
other exciting projects involve the
development of an implantable naloxone
delivery system
and the novel international delivery
method for naloxone intended to be
affordable and used in over-the-counter
settings
now let's switch our focus to potential
new format therapies
due to time constraints i won't be fully
describing the mechanisms and functions
of all these drug candidates but i would
like to emphasize that our portfolio
includes novel pharmacotherapies with
pharmacological mechanisms not acting
through the new opiate receptor
that could lead to the approval of
medications without abuse liability
these targets include the orexin
receptor the catalytic receptor
the gaba bb receptor
glutamate ampa receptors and the
nociception of your peptide receptors
just to name a few
now let's start with the early
preclinical category
all the projects in this category are
only focusing on lead compound
optimization pharmacology and some
toxicology
all of these compounds are being
developed for the treatment of oeud
except for the card sentinel humanized
monoclonal antibody with an indication
for the treatment of acute exposure to
carb fentanyl
all candidates are novel compounds
that means that they have not been
tested in humans before and will be
considered new molecular entities or any
knees by the fda
we have 12 candidates
two of them are being developed to
target the new opioid receptor
a new delta opio receptor antagonist
and a new object receptor modulator
six candidates are targeting new
pharmacological mechanisms including the
aforementioned
no inception receptors capillary opioid
receptor and direct sin receptor
but also
a beta-arresting biased allosteric
modulator of the neurotension receptor
one
a receptor type protein tyrosine
phosphatase d inhibitor of ptprd
inhibitor
a
gpr-151 antagonist
and a gene therapy based on the
expression of the glial cell line
derived neurotrophic factor
or gdns in the brain
we also are supporting the development
of four biologics including vaccines
against
fentanyl the late for clinical phase
relates to compounds with undergoing
pharmacology and toxicology studies that
are meant to support the filing of
investigational new drug applications
with fda for testing in humans
for late
for clinical candidates we have a total
of 13 projects with five of them
involving the development of compounds
targeting the new object receptor
such as our methadone and nomethine
products
a new opul-peptide partial agonist
mitogynine and methox cinemax
there are six candidates targeting new
pharmacological mechanisms
including another nociceptin receptor
antagonist
a growing system antagonist
and in an nmda receptor modulator a
dopamine d23 receptor partial agonist
and the glutamate ampa receptor
antagonist
in addition we have two biologics
one herring vaccine and a fully human
monoclonal antibody against antonyl that
is being developed for the prevention of
sentiment over there
but note rexpiprazole is currently
commercially available and is produced
by otsuka pharmaceutical
this dopamine d2 receptor partial
agonist is under development as an
adjunctive treatment to buprenorphine
maintenance therapy
we also have tissum panel the glutamate
ampa receptor antagonist a compound
already tested in humans that is
currently being developed to treat
withdrawal withdrawal symptoms
moving on to candidates in the clinical
space
i'm going to start by describing the
projects with planned or ongoing phase 1
studies first
we have 14 projects under this sub
category with only one compound
targeting the new object receptor and
that is iti 333
it is a new object peptide agonist that
has been developed by intracellular
therapies
we are very excited to have 12
candidates in clinical stages
targeting new pharmacological mechanisms
including the gaba b receptor or xin
receptors dopamine d23 receptors and the
kappaopia receptor
there is a total of seven candidates
that are new molecular entities that
have never been tested in humans before
including
asp8062 acaba b modulator by astellas
pharma
intp 2000
and ecd4041
both orexin b saturn antagonist
by interviewer and asus nanika
respectively
two compounds by cerebral therapeutics
cbl 936 and dopamine d23 receptor
antagonist
and
cbl354 a kappa opiate receptor
antagonist
and an oxycodone vaccine
with regard to already approved drugs
we have two projects using cannabidiol
to treat oud
we have lymboric sound a dual origin
receptor antagonist that is being
studied as an adjunctive treatment for
buprenorphine analysis and therapy
we also have cyborg fund
another duo or excellent receptor
antagonist that is being tested to
increase total sleep time during
withdrawal
and liver glutathione a glucogen-like
peptide 1 receptor agonist that is being
studied as a treatment for imd
ketamine an nda receptor antagonist
is being tested to improve outcomes of
individuals engaged in a rapid
non-opioid based oral metrics and
titration
followed by extended release nitroxon
maintenance
in addition there is one project testing
low vaccine in neonatal over withdrawal
syndrome
with respect to phase two studies
dtmc is chemistry
supporting the conduct of three studies
the first using cannabidiol to test the
reduction of object use and to decrease
pain in patients with chronic non-cancer
pain syndrome
the second test in the combination of
pre-gaveling with lofexidine for the
treatment of virtual symptoms and to
facilitate the transition to
extended-release naltrexone
and the last one is the study of
guantanamo and also to adrenergic
agonists
to improve substance use outcomes in
women
all these compounds are commercially
evolved
to summarize dtmc
currently supports 55 projects for the
development of pharmaceuticals intended
to treat oud
opioid orbitals and withdrawal symptoms
including candidates that do not target
the new official receptor and therefore
could lead to medications without abuse
liability
the pipeline shows a diverse portfolio
consistent of new
formulations of already approved opiates
for oud innovators new molecular
entities including small molecules and
biologics and approved drugs for other
indications
there are multiple projects involving
new longer-acting formulations of
naturaxion
buprenorphine and methadone
and projects to range it is now methane
and lamb2
there is also a novel non-oxygen
formulation with the potential to become
the first otc naloxone product if
approved
the pipeline also shows several projects
in early preclinical
laser technical and clinical stages
involving non-neopic receptor targets
such as the rxnew receptor catholic
receptor the kabbabi receptor the ampa
receptors no deception of your peptide
receptors the grayling system
and dopamine d23 receptors
finally we support several projects in
early and late clinical stages
involving biologics targeting oxycodone
herring and fentanyl
for additional information about all the
projects described in this presentation
please go to the nih reporter website
and search for the grad number linked to
each project in the pipeline
lastly i would like to spread the word
about these three funding opportunities
for anyone interested in collaborating
with us to develop medications for the
treatment
and prevention of iud and opiate objects
these concludes my presentation so thank
you for your attention